i'd like to tell you about a patient
named donna
in this photograph donna was in her mid
70s a vigorous healthy woman the
matriarch of a large clan
she had a family history of heart
disease however and one day she had the
sudden onset of crushing chest pain
now unfortunately rather than seeking
medical attention donna took to her bed
for about 12 hours until the pain passed
the next time she went to see her
physician he performed an
electrocardiogram
and this showed that she'd had a large
heart attack or a myocardial
infarction in medical parlance
after this heart attack donna was never
quite the same
her energy levels progressively waned
she couldn't do a lot of the physical
activities she'd previously enjoyed
got to the point where she couldn't keep
up with her grandkids and it was even
too much work to go out to the end of
the driveway to pick up the mail
one day her granddaughter came by to
walk the dog
and she found her grandmother dead in
the chair
doctor said it was a cardiac arrhythmia
that was secondary to heart failure
the last thing that i should tell you is
that donna was not just
an ordinary patient donna was my mother
stories like ours are unfortunately far
too common
heart disease is the number one killer
in the entire world in the united states
it's the most common reason that
patients are admitted to the hospital
and that's our number one health care
expense we spent over a hundred billion
dollars billing with a b
in this country every year on the
treatment of heart disease
just for reference that's more than
twice the annual budget of the state of
washington
what makes this disease so deadly well
it all starts with the fact that the
heart is the least regenerative organ
in the human body now a heart attack
happens when a blood clot forms
in a coronary artery that feeds blood to
the wall of the heart
so this plugs the blood flow and the
heart muscle is very metabolically
active and so it dies very quickly
within just a few hours
of have of having its blood flow
interrupted
since the heart can't grow back new
muscle it heals by scar formation
this leaves the patient with a deficit
in the amount of heart muscle that they
have
and in too many people their illness
progresses to the point where the heart
can no longer keep up with the body's
demand for blood flow
this imbalance between supply and demand
is the crux of heart failure
so when i talk to people about this
problem
i often get a shrug and a statement to
the effect of
well you know chuck we've got to die of
something
and
yeah but what this also tells me
is that we've resigned ourselves to this
as the status quo
because we have to or do we
i think there's a better way and this
better way involves the use of stem
cells as medicines
so what exactly are stem cells if you
look at them under the microscope
there's not much going on they're just
simple little round cells but that
belies two remarkable attributes
the first is they can divide like crazy
so i can take a single cell and in a
month's time i can grow this up to
billions of cells
the second is they can differentiate
or become more specialized so these
simple little round cells can turn into
skin
can turn into brain can turn into kidney
and so forth
now some tissues in our bodies are chock
full of stem cells our bone marrow for
example
cranks out billions of blood cells every
day other tissues like the heart
are quite stable and as far as we can
tell the heart lacks
in stem cells entirely so for the heart
we're going to have to bring stem cells
in from the outside
and for this we turn to the most potent
stem cell type the pluripotent stem cell
pluripotent stem cells are so named
because they can turn into any of the
240 some cell types that make up the
human body
so this is my big idea i want to take
human pluripotent stem cells
grow them up in large numbers
differentiate them into cardiac muscle
cells
and then take them out of the dish and
transplant them into the hearts of
patients who've had heart attacks
i think this is going to reseed the wall
with new muscle tissue
and this will restore contractile
function to the heart
now before you applaud too much this is
my idea 20 years ago
i thought i was young i was i was full
of it and i thought
five years in the lab and we'll crank
this out and we'll have this
into the clinic uh let me tell you what
really happened
we began with the quest to turn these
pluripotent stem cells into heart muscle
and our first experiments worked sort of
we got these little clumps of beating
human heart muscle in the dish
and that was cool because it said in
principle this should be able to be done
but when we got around to doing the cell
counts we found that only one out of a
thousand
of our stem cells were actually turning
into heart muscle
the rest was just a gameish of brain
and skin and cartilage and
intestine so how do you coax a cell that
can become
anything into becoming just a heart
muscle cell
well for this we turn to the world of
embryology and for over a century the
embryologists have been pondering the
mysteries of heart development
and they had given us what was
essentially a google map
for how to go from a single fertilized
egg all the way over to a human
cardiovascular system
so we shamelessly absconded all of this
information
and tried to make human cardiovascular
development happen in a
dish it took us about five years but
nowadays we can get 90
of our stem cells to turn into cardiac
muscle so a 900 fold improvement
so this is quite exciting this slide
shows you
our current cellular product we gr we
grow our heart muscle cells in little
three-dimensional clumps called cardiac
organoids each of them has
500 to 1000 heart muscle cells in it if
you look closely
you can see these little organoids are
actually twitching each one is beating
independently
but they've got another trick up their
sleeve we took a gene from jellyfish
that live in the pacific northwest and
we used a technique called genome
editing
to splice this gene into the stem cells
and this makes our heart muscle cells
flash green
every time they beat okay so now we were
finally ready to begin
animal experiments we took our cardiac
muscle cells and we transplanted them
into the hearts of rats that had been
given experimental heart attacks
a month later i peered anxiously down
through my microscope to see what we had
grown
and i saw nothing
everything had died but we persevered
on this and we came up with a
biochemical cocktail that we call our
pro-survival cocktail
and this was enough to allow ourselves
to survive through the stressful process
of transplantation
and now when i looked through the
microscope i could see this fresh young
human heart muscle growing back in the
injured wall of this rat's heart
so this was getting quite exciting the
next question was
will this new muscle beat in synchrony
with the rest of the heart
so to answer that we returned to the
cells that had that jellyfish gene
in them we used these cells essentially
like a space probe
that we could launch into a foreign
environment and then have that flashing
report back to us about their biological
activity
so what you're seeing here is a zoomed
in view it's a black and white image of
a guinea pig's heart that was injured
and then received three graphs of our
human cardiac muscle so you see those
sort of diagonally running white lines
each of those is a needle track that
contains a couple of million
of human cardiac muscle cells in it
and when i start the video you can see
what we saw when we looked through the
microscope
our cells are flashing and they're
flashing in synchrony
back through the walls of the injured
heart what does this mean
it means the cells are alive they're
well they're beating
and they've managed to connect with one
another so that they're beating in
synchrony
but it gets even more interesting than
this if you look at that tracing that's
along the bottom
that's the electrocardiogram from the
guinea pig's own heart
and if you line up the flashing with the
heartbeat
that's shown on the bottom what you can
see is there's a perfect one-to-one
correspondence in other words
the guinea pig's natural pacemaker is
calling the shots
and the human heart muscle cells are
following in lockstep
like good soldiers
so our current studies have moved into
what i think is going to be the best
possible predictor
of a human patient and that's into
macaque monkeys
this next slide shows you a microscopic
image from the heart of a macaque
that was treated it was given an
experimental heart attack and then
treated with a saline injection this is
essentially like
a placebo treatment to show the natural
history of the disease
the macaque heart muscle is shown in red
and in blue you see the scar tissue that
results from the heart attack
so as you look at this you can see how
there's a big deficiency in the muscle
in the in part of the wall of the heart
and it's not hard to imagine how this
heart would have a tough time
generating much force
now in contrast this is one of the stem
cell treated hearts
again you can see the the uh monkey's
heart muscle in
red but it's very hard to even see the
blue scar tissue
and that's because we've been able to
repopulate it
with the human heart muscle and so we've
got this nice
plump wall okay let's just take a second
and recap
i've showed you that we can take our
stem cells and differentiate them into
cardiac muscle
we learned how to keep them alive after
transplantation
we showed that they beat in synchrony
with the rest of the heart
and we've shown that we can scale them
up into an animal that is the best
possible predictor
of a human's response you'd think
that we hit all the roadblocks that lay
in our path
right turns out not
these macaque studies also taught us
that our human heart muscle cells
created a period of electrical
instability they cause ventricular
arrhythmias or irregular heartbeats for
several weeks after we transplanted them
this was quite unexpected because we
hadn't seen this in smaller animals
we've studied it extensively and it
turns out that it results from the fact
that our
cellular grafts are quite immature and
immature heart muscle cells
all act like pacemakers so what happens
is we put them into the heart
and there starts to be a competition
with the heart's natural pacemaker over
who gets to call the shots it would be
sort of like if you brought a whole
gaggle
of teenagers into your orderly household
all at once
and they don't want to follow the rules
and the rhythms of the the way you run
things
and it takes a while to rein everybody
in and get people uh working in a
coordinated fashion
so our plans at the moment are to make
the cells go through this
troubled adolescence period while
they're still in the dish
and that should and then we'll
transplant them in in the
post-adolescent phase
where they should be much more orderly
and be ready to listen to their marching
orders
in the meantime it turns out we can
actually do quite well by treating with
anti-arrhythmia drugs as well
so one big question still remains and
that
is of course the whole purpose that we
set out to do this can we
actually restore function to the injured
heart
to answer this question we went to
something that's called left ventricular
ejection fraction
ejection fraction is simply the amount
of blood that is squeezed out of the
chamber of the heart
with each beat now in healthy macaques
like in healthy people
ejection fractions are about 65 percent
after a heart attack ejection fraction
drops down to about 40 percent
so these animals are well on their way
to heart failure and the animals receive
a placebo injection when we scan them a
month later
we see that ejection fraction is
unchanged because the heart of course
doesn't spontaneously recover
but in every one of the animals that
received a graft of human cardiac muscle
cells
we see a substantial improvement in
cardiac function
this average eight points so from 40 to
48 percent
what i can tell you is that eight points
is better
than anything that's on the market right
now for treating patients with heart
attacks
it's better than everything we have put
together so if we could do eight points
in the clinic
i think this would be a big deal that
would make a large impact on human
health
but it gets more exciting
that was just four weeks after
transplantation if we extend these
studies out to three months
we get a full 22 point gain in ejection
fraction
function in these treated hearts is so
good that if we didn't know
up front that these animals had a heart
attack we would never be able to tell
from their functional stuff excuse me
they're functional studies
so going forward our plan is to start
phase one
first in human trials here at the
university of washington in 2020.
so two short years from now presuming
these studies
are safe and effective which i think
they're going to be
our plan is to scale this up and ship
these cells
all around the world for the treatment
of patients with heart disease
given the global burden of this illness
i could easily imagine this treating a
million or more patients a year
so i envision a time maybe a decade from
now where a patient like my mother will
have
actual treatments that can address the
root cause and not just manage
her symptoms this all comes from the
fact that stem cells give us the ability
to repair the human body
from its component parts in the not too
distant future
repairing humans is going to be
something that is going to go from
something that is far-fetched
science fiction into common medical
practice
and when this happens it's going to have
a transformational effect that rivals
the development
of vaccinations and antibiotics
thank you for your attention